[Music]
by a show of hands how many people have
ever been on a bad first date as I
expected most of you is anyone brave
enough to share a story from that bad
first day I saw your hand shoot no level
of attraction will make that work
luckily for you and the rest of the
class we're here today to talk to you
about how to make a great first
impression on a date and give you five
got key tips and categories that we
think will help and if you want put us
in contact with that dentist and we'll
sit down without now Andre I know what
you're thinking you're engaged and Bert
you're married this doesn't apply to you
but we think that it does because
throughout your life you're gonna be
making first impressions with everyone
that you meet so the first tip that
we're going to talk about is eye contact
eye contact it's kind of like your
superpower use it well and it can have
magical effects but use it poorly and it
can be an absolute disaster showy eye
contact shows your date that you have
confidence you have warmth and that
you're actually listening to what
they're saying in fact studies show that
if you don't show eye contact your date
probably thinks that you're hiding
something but it's important to note
that showing too much eye contact can
actually freak your date out you don't
want to just stare them down
let's take Andrew and Barbara
they're on their first date let's check
in and see how it's going how's it going
on the end really good a decent day you
know bye so I'm just gonna stop this
right there
really that's not going well research
shows that the right amount of eye
contact is about seven to ten seconds
meaning that you show eye contact with
your date for about seven to ten seconds
and then you break the gaze you look
down and you look out the window before
we engaging with eye contact let's try
that again hey I'm Andrew how's it going
I'm great I'm excited to have this
dinner drink this Pinot it's looking
delicious absolutely that was much
better and much more now 36% of people
say that their greatest anxiety on a
first date is awkward silence so how can
we create conversation that will prevent
that awkward silence the first thing you
want to do is you want to ask
interesting yet risky questions avoid
questions like where'd you go to school
where do you work and instead just like
touchy feely push yourself to be in that
15% risk zone but don't go further than
that so instead of those questions why
don't you try some questions like these
Barbara what makes you unique pop
culture I like to think I'm great at
singing Mariah Carey in the shower these
types of questions build a deeper level
of personal intimacy and connection my
next tip is to shoot for about 50% air
time don't speak more than that and
don't speak less than that my only
caveat to that would be if you tend to
find yourself being overly shy or talk a
lot maybe adjust that percentage higher
or lower respectively
then finally one of the leading
contributors to a failed feed is her
Hurst lines and jokes these don't work
well Andrew why don't you tell a joke to
work with hey Barbara where did the cows
go in their first date to the movies
that date is over now the corollary
conversation is active listening and
when the other person is speaking make
sure you were being an active listener
and I'll give you four tips for that the
first is maintain eye contact nod your
head when the other person is speaking
have a warm open body posture that's
facing them and then last ask
interesting questions to show that
you're actually paying attention to what
they're saying the most important thing
you can do with your body
on the first date is smile smiling is
actually an extremely effective way to
make a good first impression
and there's a couple reasons for that
first of all smiling is contagious when
you smile at people they want to smile
back and secondly when you smile you
create a bit of a halo effect for
yourself someone sees you smiling and
they start to associate you with more
positive qualities and see you in a
better lens but it's critical that you
don't fake your smile just showing your
teeth as much as possible really does
not count as a smile so bad let's see
those pearly whites
not too good right Katelyn show us a
real smile much much better the bottom
line is smile frequently and smile
authentically don't fake it it's easy to
tell you're faking it moving past your
smile though you can really use the rest
of your body to convey comfort
engagement and excitement research shows
there's a few things you can do with
your body to really to really accentuate
your partner's opinion if you keep your
arms uncrossed and loose try to get
closer to your partner although not too
close we don't want anything unseemly
and then physically lean in to show your
engagement in the conversation and
finally take measured and subdued
emotions you don't want to be a statue
but you also don't want to be the person
waving their arms around you
much acting overly eager or nervous or
excited now on the other hand there's
also some research that may indicate
there are some actions you don't want to
take with your body one of which is you
don't want to if you're someone who you
know rubs the back of your neck or
touches your hair a bunch or touches
your face you look uncomfortable a
little bit unconfident as well you don't
want to look overly aloof and sit back
from the conversation and appear
disengaged were you also especially for
men may not want to come off as too
macho with your body with your chest all
puffed out and then finally this seems
like a bit of a subtlety but we don't
recommend pointing your feet and your
body towards the nearest exit because it
literally looks like you're at bracing
yourself to leave the situation as soon
as possible now I'm supplementing your
body your voice is also a very critical
mode a very critical aspect of making a
good first impression your voice tends
to mimic how you're feeling and how your
your your internal state you could say
earlier this quarter JD showed us some
research that indicated about 90% of
your communicational impact on someone
comes from your visual and your vocal
aspects in other words if you're not
showing it you're not saying it the
right way it's not gonna land well so
let's check in on Ben and Caitlin again
and see how this dates going okay well
I'm having such a great time tonight not
very convincing right by not using more
of a more variation in his tone more
variation in his pitch Ben does not seem
very convincing
research has actually shown that you can
hear a smile through the phone so
there's no way Caitlin will be convinced
in this case and it's critical that Ben
make another attempt and this time put
his voice with him really put his voice
into it
Caitlin I'm having a really great time
now the next thing you want to do
is to subtly mimic I know what some of
you are thinking I was kid my sibling
would mimic me and was incredibly
annoying please don't do that
on your first date subtlety is the key
here what you don't want to do is mimic
all of the crazy of scary gestures that
your date might do and you especially
don't want to exactly repeat all of
their sentences isn't it ESP the most
amazing place ever
yeah the GSB is the most amazing place
clearly it doesn't sound like they're
engaging and they don't have anything
new to say but what you can do if you
subtly mimic your date is actually
increased empathy likeability and your
attractiveness to your date studies show
that just by subtly mimicking their
movements and their voice they won't
actually become more attractive to you
probably one of the easiest ways to do
this so the first thing you can do is to
mirror some of their small gestures with
about a 1 to 2 seconds away this will
show that you're engaged just like they
are the next thing you can do is to
repeat some of the key phrases that they
use this shows that you're both
listening but also can add something to
the conversation I had such an
incredible time at the GSB particularly
taking 3:15 and finally you want to
mimic the formality of your date so if
your date is being very formal in the
way they speak and the way they dress
you probably want to meet them at
Grenier at their level but if they're
very laid-back they're casual you
probably don't want to be speaking like
the Queen so again try to meet them at
their level and everyone will feel more
comfortable now once your date is over
it's really important to have clear
follow-up if you had a good time tell
your date and make clear plans to see
them again studies show that people
really appreciate assertiveness and
clarity so let's see how
good day twins hey I had a great time
tonight me too
let's do it again soon perfect how about
next Tuesday 8:00 p.m. at the patio
sounds great see you then just as
important if you didn't have a good
first time or a good time on your first
date or for some reason you don't want
to see the person again it's equally as
important to tell them that way there's
no uncertainty so let's see how that
would go hey I had a great time tonight
hey Ben it was great getting to know you
but I just didn't feel a spark between
us good luck out there I know you'll
find someone amazing hi Kailen I'm
bummed to hear that but thanks for being
up front of me hope you find what you're
looking for so we hope you've enjoyed
hearing these five tips for how to ace
your first date and make a really great
first impression and now we'd love to
take any questions you guys have
[Music]